now to the war on our southern border
last week we told you about a drug
cartel extermination site just a few
miles from the u.s border in nuevo
laredo where in a single room in a
ruined house they found countless
compacted burnt human remains nearly two
feet deep and now just earlier this week
the u.s consulate in that same border
city of nuevo loredo was forced to close
temporarily after it was hit by gunfire
following the rest of our of cartel boss
juan gerardo travino known as el huevo
what you're seeing on your screen right
now is the aftermath of that gun battle
where suspected gang members blocked
roads with spike strips and lit several
tractor trailers on fire at least one
person is known to have died as a result
of the violence this isn't a war
happening half the world away as you can
see right here on this map
nuevo laredo is just on the other side
of the texas border this is all
happening steps away from sovereign
american territory we barely even hear
about it and it's just about to get even
worse with the biden regime now
predicting a mass migration event at the
border and a quote massive influx of
migrants as if we haven't had that
already where's alejandro majorcas
where's border tsar kamala harris
looking into the root causes of this is
jen sarki gonna circle back to it we'd
love to know
joining us now with reaction is ed
calderon a former baja california state
police officer ed
um
just give tell us what what in your view
is going on i mean we hear about the
cartels basically running everything
and then you see these battles erupting
as an indication of that what's
happening
and they they are they are putting they
they are taking the world to school in
fourth generation warfare these are not
small state actors anymore these are
transnational entities that have
capabilities to take down aircraft they
are people that can basically take a
whole city and own it and beat the
military
these are these are groups that are now
acting more like a guerrilla warfare
force
than anything else that we've actually
seen as far as cartels
and what is the impact on
the
the border situation specifically does
because because the crime that they're
involved in the drug trafficking the
people's is that is that all just
exponentially going to increase if this
continues unchecked
so people need to realize that main part
of the the the draw that some of these
cartels get as far as influx of money
actually comes from people from
smuggling people across the border so
all of these mass migration waves that
have been hitting the border have only
emboldened and enriched it's a lot of
these cartels they are the one that tax
people that go through their points of
entry
uh
this uh you know going the first 72
hours of the war in ukraine mexico
actually beat
the ukraine as far as the amount of
deaths related to violence uh
you know these mass body sites that were
found are one of many you know the
numbers that the governments are that
the government of mexico is putting out
as far as how many people have died
violently in mexico are skewed
they don't take into account the people
that are missing
uh
it's getting worse that's an amazing
amazing fact there um and what do you
has the mexican government
lost control through uh
incompetence the superior kind of
firepower of the cartels or do you think
they've just given up they're not
interested in doing anything about this
well we you know you have to realize
that the current mexican president isn't
uh you know is to the left of the
political spectrum it's populist open
chavista open maduro supporter
and his first uh his first uh you know
thing that he claimed as far as his uh
anti-drug policy anti-cartel policy was
abraso's
you know hugs not bullets so
we have had some major arrests recently
uh but you can see that a lot of it has
been concentrated on some of the smaller
cells
uh some of the smaller groups that are
kind of fracturing off of some of the
bigger ones like the new generation
cartel that has been growing
exponentially across the country and the
classic large sinaloa cartel that has
held control over vast amounts of the
mexican territory years
there is simply no political
effort being done really to try and stop
some of these uh groups from growing
or at least you know again some of these
groups own the sky over the territories
that they own
and they beat the military in open
warfare uh
you can see the government getting
smaller
wow that is just absolutely chilling to
hear that what ex really appreciate your
expertise and the frightening thing is
we don't see that political will to do
anything about it on this side of the
border either
ed calderon thank you so much for
joining us we really appreciate it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else